[Music]
okay
hello everyone since the everyone
already started to join too many
participants yes there are quite quite a
lot of participants and the first for
our grandmasters and yeah seven out of
ten are grandmasters on the first page
4750 one player so far and I think all
for joining so fast
quite quite incredible now as you all
know we've joined here to to have a
nicely chess arena which will be two
hours of two minutes plus a zero second
increment as we usually do here then
we're gonna have some fun and games but
this is a this time it's a bit of a
different as it coincides with the
delecious titled arena so as soon as our
arena ends Alicia style arena starts so
we're gonna be playing some games
accepting challenges of course and but
we will be checking up on delicious
title arena you know just just for good
measure so to say so I would I would
like to welcome a Yan Almighty to to the
livestream hello Jana Thank You thinking
taking the time from your busy schedule
to join us here on this and this great
day yeah for sure for sure I'm always
glad to be in the first row to see this
a very great achievement of having half
a million subscribers so always glad to
be here thank you for inviting me thank
you thank you for coming once again yeah
thanks man let's have a nice beer yeah
of course always a good way to start a
stream yes but I already see some rocket
rakia calls in the comments in the chat
yes that will come later
yeah when the tournament starts so uh
what what what
did I want to mention so for those of
you who do not know before when we had
the titled arena or not the titled arena
but when we had an arena you had a link
to the tournament it's the same now it's
doing to the tournament is in the
description below so just click on it
this time there is no password so
everyone is invited the only the only
criteria to enter the tournament is that
you have to play at least 40 games it's
not 120 this time it's 40 since the
prize fund is a bit larger so to avoid
the cheaters as much as possible we're
still probably gonna have cheaters but
you know that cannot be avoided and we
do have 13 minutes till the start of the
tournament so we could accept some
challengers and before that is
everything okay with the stream
you know audio wise and the video wise
so if anyone can just say everything is
fine with the stream that would be great
yeah okay yes in the spirit of Michael
Tao okay
so when you're yeah
yes you should usually definitely but
used to use the separate tab so we don't
mess up the the tournament tab what what
is the deal so we will accept what kind
of shamea but not this tab not this time
okay just right haha right click here oh
I don't I don't know if you can right
click on the arrow can you right click
on the arrow here let's try on this
let's try it nope no okay but yeah you
have one here okay all right so just
yeah you can accept any of them but it
has to be in not it has to be casual an
unrated since we're both gonna be using
my account and we're gonna have some
guests here which will also be playing
so we cannot we can't use well a rated
account wouldn't be fair and I think
it's against you know leeches rules to
use for multiple people to use the same
account for rated games so for now I'm
just gonna start with three plus so
maybe later a bullet game yes we just
have fun it's GB r99 hello sir hello sir
thank you for the thank you for the
greeting
camera a bit over the board camera is a
bit over the board is it nope no I don't
think so okay
um you watch the chat mr. mr. Alex Lang
Lang rogue donated $2 yes that's that's
a new thing in as of I think as of last
week super chat is allowed in Croatia
really people are actually it's actually
possible to donate during the live chat
I don't I do not encourage anyone to do
so you know but if you must you know I I
will not stop you okay so I just gotta
say that I haven't been playing for
quite a long time now so I'm just gonna
take a few to warm up okay yeah sure aha
they say the the camera the camera
source is uh over the notations but I
don't see how okay okay you deal with
that and I will try all right not to
lose them yes I don't think you you
can't put some time in a three minute
game thank you Alex Brasil ski like you
don't know me it's like yeah do what
Rick and Morty
I haven't watch the latest episode yeah
there's the one way that were they go
into the inception you know mode and
it's like dream inside of a Dream Eater
oh yeah it's like you don't know me okay
let's try to be okay well you you you
basically already won this yeah it's a
very nice nice position you have there
yeah this King doesn't feel too safe I
gotta say but we're gonna still protect
my point
hello hello to India yes we will be
dealing quite a lot with India as we do
have the Tata Steel India Edition at the
moment and I didn't manage to cover all
that many games today only the one cost
and vs. Nakamura but they were the
leaders after they won so I guess that's
that is sufficient but I will try to
squeeze in some more
tomorrow morning before the start of day
three
what's ferocious nickname unleashes I
think it's all Araiza Oh F thank you
Pantera sgb for a two-pound donation sir
okay I don't know I'm thinking I'm
thinking huh we might we might put all
the donations as a prize fund for the
next tournament but but not not a big
one like this maybe maybe a smaller one
without titles players you know so so
everyone gets a chance so you know the
good thing about this tournament is that
a lira is a joint but okay the bad thing
about the tournament is also the
holidays because you you know you might
get a chance to play him on the other
hand it's very unlikely that you'll
actually win the tournament well give
people a chance you never know yeah you
never know but yeah okay
positive is both net positive Adnan he
all accessory a positive so once again
have people from all around the world am
I gonna flee the tournament no I I work
too much for the entire year that today
we're just we're just gonna enjoy some
games buy some really good players oh
come on yeah okay yeah it would be it
would be too stressful but we are gonna
play some games after the tournament
yeah for sure
cannot go without that all right it's
Bjorn Goodman son donating three 300
squatting is probably Icelandic
something well if it is son in his
surname then probably he is it a crooner
do they also have that I don't know I'm
not sure like maybe I should know that
but I don't really know yeah
where is mr. calculator friend he's so
funny and so and so low I don't know I
are you referring to the daughter the
engine boy oh man yeah so long daughter
but he's still very strong he's still
silent and still deadly man this King is
like really going everywhere was the
poster on Vladimir Vasilyevich ah here
we have Icelandic Manny's chrono oh it
is yeah let me have it
a lot of countries have very nice thank
you thank you guys crowns so there's a
queen even with a chick
oh look at this beautiful look at this
beautiful checkmate 98 oh very nice you
know it's still the first game yeah yeah
okay I will check so how long do we have
we have five minutes five minute maybe a
bulletin that's it
okay let's see and then we hear okay the
first 100 you open anyway right no good
for you yeah yeah
fortunately yeah okay so gotta play fast
huh
yeah well you have a good rating dude
yeah that's me
Wow guys haven't played bullets in a
while okay no uh yeah I think I think I
I was like at twenty one eighty and then
I saw Colonel Dina was 2190 and then I
just got it 20200 just for fun
hey mr. radish hello from the
Philippines thank you for the
contribution mr. nany
we will do our best to keep up the good
work
okay that's Europe apiece and okay I
guess
oh you have ht3 hoof yeah the words
thank you mister soon the masala okay we
have people from Algeria South Africa
New York and Texas in the house that's
very nice
that's a queen yeah yeah I think you can
squeeze in one more bullet yeah just a
quick one
yeah if there's a casual donkey kong
okay with with the sea we remember him
oh it's it's a dawn yeah it's a donkey
monk with a see yeah
I gotta be interesting game okay a
French yeah feel free to pause the
stream and and try to read the car
comments they are quite fast I gotta say
yeah okay this is this is impossible but
yeah we have Toronto also in the house
we have Canada India Israel oh we also
have Croatia here
what is Prague was nickname yeah Prague
was also playing he's playing under the
nickname pragna nonde although I've had
some comments from my Indian followers
and they say it's actually Prague Anandi
not pregnant I don't know that are they
just trolling me or if that's true but
if it is then I've been mispronouncing
it for for a very long time a long time
yeah me too
yeah this is like more of a dragon and
but who know how to pronounce every name
oh we have Colonel Dino is now 22 36 oh
man don't have to get it to 2250 you
gotta step up your game yeah okay this
is gonna be a close one
okay we have people from Brazil Saudi
Arabia Pakistan we have since an Ohio
are there any Swedish players I'm sure
there are I don't know if they are here
thank you argent for the for the
contribution thank you sir ah five
thousand and five hundred players so we
are one thousand short to beat the
beating our previous tournament I think
we'll be able to do it
previous tournament was
6500 so it'd be nice if we if we could
do it okay yes
remove remove for the window five yes
yes okay that'll work that'll work
no what's that what's that what's what
okay admit okay there was a bit of a lag
huh yeah there was yeah maybe because we
have five overlays now instead of three
so yeah I think that's that's sufficient
yeah penguin versus all it is it will be
fun I'm I'm really gonna enjoy that okay
so now that I've warmed up
thank you guys for the games they were
really nice yeah I think it's just about
time to relax and wait for ya and as
usual I'm naming you tournament director
So You Think You Man you can choose any
game you want to check out well if you
say you want if I say okay I want to see
Magnus play and you say no way man it's
no Magnus okay okay but we have to
withdraw yeah we have to withdraw we're
all gonna be in it we're just gonna
enjoy the show nice man how can you get
3135 rating on leeches so I haven't been
playing for a long time well basically
you have to be tender grandma say you
can do that 500 130 for me okay I wanna
see allies of course in the first game
it's only fair I think it you will show
it automatically oh yeah okay or maybe
it will not show anything at all but
there's something there oh that's still
your Donkey Kong oh yeah it's of course
the
I think it's some 15 seconds
so um maybe a bit more should i refresh
it yeah I mean that's what's reloaded
there's no harm in that
oh we draw again because I didn't what
Oh
too many requests oh man we broke
leeches that's okay
come on leeches yeah that's that's
that's unfortunate you know it's funny
my girlfriend asked if anything if
there's a chance that anything can go
wrong with the tournament I said that
will only fully chase alicia's you know
break stuff okay that it's okay hmm all
right let's just grab that let's not go
into panic mode
yeah no zero in the tournament here so
[Music]
should be fine but okay I would guess
that the site cannot be reached with one
of many players wanting to play in such
a tournament
yeah it could happen no I don't think I
don't think that's the problem okay
I think leeches come on that's that's
just weird okay okay so leeches is
officially down yeah is leeches
officially down or just try to see any
website no wait leeches is sending me a
message they need to whitelist me for
some reason okay okay we are gonna be
okay sorry for it it will only take a
few seconds let me just copy that and
inform leeches that we are we are game
all right there it is yeah they say they
have to whitelist me
for some reason there you go good thing
I'm checking my phone I always think
it's a route to check my phone when I'm
streaming but they said yeah this is
special occasion yeah yeah yeah good
good thing mr. ding
I'll get matter on the blacklist okay
yeah we're just gonna wait for a couple
seconds and I think we'll be good yeah
the things are being handled as we speak
yeah why do they have to whitelist us
that's really weird
I don't know the official chrome white
screen of death yeah okay I think I
think something is happening something
is definitely happening maybe they'll
let us through huh but okay the
tournament is definitely still playing
yeah I think they're the stream health
is okay so Internet is fine should be
fine
yeah Internet is fine and okay stream
health is medium but okay it's a very
strange huh okay let me just check here
is if it's if Internet yeah I know it's
working fine this is a do I have ready
you know for the for the giveaway all
right wow this is this is super strange
this is the first yeah everyone is
blacklisted by default yeah okay let me
just check if they if they are informing
me of anything nope doesn't seem so but
okay as far as I can see my purse should
grab my phone just to see if the
tournament is on yeah they said well
well they said that it could be also a
tournament crash no they said that
everything should work fine now huh no
they say oh it's not they say that they
have to terminate terminate it and
create it again
oh the tournament yeah this is a very
strange this never
almost never happens but well you are
breaking barriers yes the YouTube world
so why not in the legend okay
I'm good to know okay
there the people are saying that
tournament is not working as okay and I
can try to rebut oh ok leeches will
create a new tournament probably one not
lasting two hours but lasting like an
hour and fifteen fifty minutes so we
don't coincide with Leisha styled arena
and as soon as they send me the link I
will provide you the link in the
description below okay
Wow I thought it's Alicia I thought
leeches was one of those sites where it
was impossible to crash well huh
breaking barriers yes sorry strange
maybe we could go for some chest jokes
okay we just says they are creating it
now okay ah so nice if any of you guys
brought some chest jokes now now would
be the time that would be the great time
all right
yeah and it was in this position that
Alicia's resigned the game I see yeah
yeah but also there's a lawyer
1200 twelve hours back that was four
hours back normally okay really you can
so you can stream for 12 hours and it
will be a long video yeah because I
remember a year ago it was uh it was
four hours and that's why I always had
four hour stream so I didn't have to
record I'm lazy but yeah I mean four
hours yeah this is quite enough okay
let's try it again
leeches dorg ah
come on baby yeah I can seem to me show
me the money
try control it our control shift refresh
why just
because it's not normal refresh maybe it
cleans das should be different okay do
you think my DuckDuckGo has anything to
do with it I don't think so I'm not sure
because maybe it's caching something
Chrome and okay we have the link to the
new arena let me just let me just paste
it over to you guys all right let's see
it alright seems to be working okay
alright a few seconds more something is
definitely happening yeah okay okay
nope what that's really weird let me
just quickly can get everything out of
this is just checking if it's maybe it's
browser related I don't think so okay
oh you're your programmer
you know ya can do something man my
expertise are the following
when websites are down there don't I
come in that's what I do it's working
okay so basically although I can't enter
it for some reason you guys like yeah is
there a copy link address okay guys I'm
adding the link to the description the
new link here it is okay the link has
been updated and just refresh it and you
will just automatically be placed into
the new tournament and here it is yeah I
don't think
maybe I have an option maybe of pinning
my comment or something like that no
even if okay what about yeah yeah let's
check it out and open just remove okay
so the link is in the description below
yeah open new tab that's yeah this this
guy I mean at this point I'll try
anything
okay works all right hmm
very strange
they say we should be whitelisted I know
you are now choosing the the latest like
the last ocean yeah yeah okay
troubleshooting with Windows yeah
trouble like the last okay pretty much
the last option there okay at least I
won three games so yeah just look at the
bright side
huh okay so oh okay
awesome so you've seen the arena there
okay I'll back whoa amazing okay mister
tournament director whoa ah he's online
but isn't responding to attempts okay
well we don't care about that anymore
okay we're back there go mr. tournament
director you're welcome to choose a game
but now we have only nine nineteen okay
it's 2,000 already okay a little bit of
a shame but let's just jump into the
first game and hopefully it will okay
III just informed bleachers that
everything is working fine now
can you call Magnus please yeah yeah
okay just click on the game yeah that's
right okay
amazing
I mean honestly like I would look at all
this as a positive thing yeah definitely
like it's okay let me just check
something as yeah okay everything is
should be working now why is the video
blurred ah probably need better okay we
still I think we still need a few
minutes for everything to start working
properly no apologies for the technical
difficulties but yeah when you're having
such a yeah popular stream
a normal just enormous number of
participants I guess yeah I don't think
it's that we're still below the number
of the previous stream so I think I
think we should be we should be okay
here it is Saturday
yeah it is Saturday but what's people
off work so I don't know it's trying to
think of reasons all right yeah that is
true you need 40 rated games all right
so now we're finally back nice good all
right although it seems like seems like
there's too big of a delay between what
happens in the stream and between real
time like 30 seconds I think before it
was like 15 yeah yeah I know this is
well because this game we've been
watching at least a minute or something
and here we just appeared so yeah but
okay it's not like ice cream that often
see it's 1 a.m. for me okay
so I think everything is uh I think
everything should be working now since
the stream health is at only a minimum
minimum I don't think if you will be
able to run it at full for a high
definition but hopefully everything is
working now so if anyone can once again
tell us is everything working dude do
you see the tournament do you see the
stream is the audio fine is the video
fine so just that will do nicely
yeah the ravitch are over to WH oh hello
mr. Satan okay so is this three in 60
frames per second I have no idea
okay stream is working fine all okay and
everyone is everyone is responding like
30 seconds after I ask the question so I
think that we've we've realized what's
the delay okay so we have Federico do we
know who Federico is well it's a person
from Argentina okay not mistake yeah we
don't know who that is
okay there was a reason yeah he thought
maybe he has three seconds three seconds
okay okay but I yeah there's no way
normally to remove this like we'll see
maybe oh they have the same identical
rating whoa nice very good checkmate
yeah but he doesn't like him okay he
didn't flag him okay it's nice that we
have like players here but also top
games over here so I'm gonna chop to all
erasers game because we missed it
because of the technical difficult and
we still have to reach the number as we
we had like 4,000 over for know we have
a 555 558 him but okay you know it's
only numbers is Jerry streaming I don't
know probably
Jerry streams a lot so so he could be
streaming at some point yes they say
that the video is blurred because of my
internet connection that could be could
be true but you know it's been fine
whoa okay yeah but for most of the time
oh Allah Reza want and if you win
against a player with 2750 you get one
rating point if you're all erisa just
let that sink in yeah so it is crazy
okay so here's a four placed also going
good but I would like to choose another
game if ya there's any game whoever
started just enjoy the game okay mr.
Rothfeld says it's not blurry so let's
let's go with that yeah for some people
oh let me just fix that all right
this is also part of the stream no I I
heard there was too big of a sound when
pieces move okay now it's maybe too low
okay all right that will do okay so so
glad that we're back on track now yes
here's the being back on track
definitely right on like hopefully won't
happen again at this point like it will
we also have a two hour tournament oh
yeah that was a blunder so let's get
back to the tournament uh yeah I know
there is still time I mean
to reach those numbers okay what we just
said yeah well it just says sorry about
that
Oh what of what about some other okay
bullet nerd that's an interesting name
bullet nerd all right but I think you
finished
okay or or yeah okay yeah I I thought
maybe in time I thought maybe the or the
mines rapper delecious crashed again
yeah II Marley says which song a
wandering voting but we're still having
the vote we're gonna run it for at least
a week okay for the moment it's Paul
Morphy I think followed by Karpov and
then a unit polgár so I don't think
Petrosyan has a chance but you know
anything can still happen maybe a
hundred thousand people decide to vote
tomorrow and but you know that doesn't
happen even in elections so yeah until
we're very unlikely until when will you
well I'm gonna keep it for a week we
it's been running for three days now so
I guess okay four more
yeah okay okay most people don't think
that we should do a Murphy saga because
the games are against inferior opponents
but you know first of all that's not
morphus fault I mean he just if he had
better opponents he would play even
better most likely and well I don't know
yeah I think it's it's worth the saga
because there can be like really really
every video can be have great stories
and there are a lot of things you can
find out about morphe so well I'm gonna
try and find a find him out and
hopefully yeah condense them into a nice
saga but and for Karpov saga well that's
that would be a really big saga that
would be like we did the capo Blanca
saga for almost a year maybe a year
maybe eight months but still and we
didn't even cover most of the games okay
so what do we have here so the situation
is
why he's trying to convert the advantage
of having a piece and I don't think
there will be a problem
yeah but black so Rebecca and this mate
is the road so this what I like almost
just seeing that in a glimpse yes they
have to capture it I mean just for sure
yeah for sure just move in do we go out
but okay with two seconds on the clock
buzzer we still be a positive where is
meadow meadow is chilling here like a
boss he's you know literally chilling
he's very you know warm I would say Oh a
typical sacrifice Bishop on h2 with the
chance of check and the dead game for
the player in the first place currently
Papa see and yet there there is no like
okay okay thank you for very very nice
very sportsmen like yeah okay so like to
see so far this has been a terrible
stream because we haven't probably done
anything for the past 15 minutes
we've drink some beers so yeah okay I
didn't mean it was terrible for us it
was nice it's fine for us
yeah half the time it was the white
screen of death yeah Rome but still yeah
works now so let's just move on to
another game can i name all the
grandmasters participating here i don't
know since the the tournament crashed so
i don't know who joined but I see how it
is I still hear Grandmaster inventing
inventions also still here okay he has a
nice core against ali reza you are the 2
out of 6 is a nice score against ali
reza yeah I think Magnus would be fine
with that
going with a crazy variation and a
French what ya got a surprise him ok ok
this is like oh this is that's upon all
this French knowledge in one minute I I
can't take this
this point is going places mr. X X is
asking when is the giveaway that is an
excellent question the giveaway will
happen well maybe maybe we should do the
giveaway right after the tournament so
we you don't have to do that anymore
or maybe we do it at the end does the
elitist Idol Arena start right after the
trip yes it will it will coincide 5
minutes because of because the the
tournament broke for some reason okay
okay
but then okay we catch a little bit of
it with with a giveaway and then with
yeah and we're using the same website
will it be rigged well of course you
know we wouldn't be doing it live if it
was rigged you know if it was rigged I
would just say you know
jung-hwan the giveaway yeah forever like
yeah yeah he won all 10 the 10 prizes
I've been here for five or six streams
and you know persistence pays exactly
where is the engine boy he's busy you
know he married he has a baby now so he
can just go around you know his dreams
busy doing engine type stuff so yeah
don't worry about it
yeah but okay still we I think we're
doing nicely
okay the stream health is still at a
medium but I don't have some people over
here so they might be hogging the the
the bandwidth but it's still chessboard
I think we'll be fine okay interesting
situation all the reza managed to warn
ya like I'm sort of just even forgot
when you have a 93 inches change he won
the exchange and it has a very nice
spawn on f7 but this night is deadly you
know the night in the Queen yeah
night nights at freaky bastard yeah okay
but looking through yeah I mean or no
okay oh it finds Aldean out of that
is a fine position to remember okay very
good in inventing invention yeah why not
why not so drawing against other seven
rating points house ping we're doing
penguin doing Oh Burger King of course
everyone okay yeah I gotta see that
so first game from him playing against
rhodius yeah okay the general opinion is
that it will be mostly between penguin
all it is a Rebecca Harris but you never
know you know some unrated player might
and might you know stroll in and and
take it off for sure for sure yeah
Artemyev is the future king well he's
definitely under on the right path I
don't know if he okay he plays the
Duchess calm speed championship but I
don't know if he like joins bullet
arenas online for for you know for fun
or for money but so very interesting
position where the penguin will go into
this and game being 40 seconds down but
I guess not a problem for him yeah he
could he could play the same game with
12 seconds yeah same amount of material
yes what would you do probably they
played before at some point but okay
that's just me that's just insane you
know something when you watch your
penguin stream and then he plays hyper
bullet and then he berserks he has 15
seconds and then he you know texts
messages and plays showing up yeah I
don't think he's showing off no I think
it's just you know second language to
him okay oh gee - okay window
so that was 3 and 18 seconds I think
that that will be enough for him Oh
juicy ponds the h-bomb god that's it
that's it my man okay that's okay he's
not even gonna try 14 seconds against
the penguin no no sir okay okay
amazing so Elmo I'll see em okay we
still have unrated players in the top 10
so that usually means either you know Oh
I remember the night yeah a nice King I
think night King won third place in one
of my tournaments okay let's check him
over the freedom master Lecter ah but
did he double berserk how is he I'm
thirty seconds that guy also is taking a
nice walk with the king okay
I think that that'd be should be another
win III then the bishop is coming to f5
f5 yeah okay
not straight check oh there's Bishop and
Queen beautiful that's a bishop pair
from hell and the Papas is still in in
first place okay unrated
39 points so 13 points in front of ya
huh I don't want to say anything
this suggests that way let's just wait
but I'm gonna check out some other GM's
okay in the top 10 so mr. Jadhav playing
against Felix I don't know how to
pronounce it but yeah you know Yosa
or something you know sir Jadhav should
dive yes Magnus Carlsen
I don't think Magnus is playing well
since he is probably busy preparing for
the for the Tata Steel India and also I
don't think he plays on leeches you know
ever since he his company merger with
just 24 yeah we had a discussion just
before it would be nice to see him but
yeah we realized that probably I don't
think he played on leeches ever since
the merger so yeah that's a shame
okay that's a six right there yeah yeah
that's quite easily but okay you have
now to passed pawns very close but I
don't know there were no buzzer no oh
it's a clean game yes I can reread this
mr. Lars Mima yeah white is winning this
should be winning this oh thank you mr.
quakes
okay I've only allowed the super chat
like a week ago so I've never actually
seen these emotes but they're quite nice
it'd be nicer if they if they had some
chess emotes yeah I always saw that in
the on the US youtube channel yeah it
only came to Croatia like a week ago or
maybe two weeks ago so was there any
reason why it was no idea they just
decided Croatia wasn't worth it I guess
I'm not surprised
yeah Sabrina can I ask you to be
determined director
yeah sure for a second no problem no
problem we're gonna we're gonna enjoy
this rook in the game where black is up
a whole rook so a young Jew stuff some
type of endgame and the white
immediately resigns okay let's view the
tournament
okay purpose is still still in the lead
but let's see let's see what happens
there the leader of the tournament the
posse do we have a from from Greece
against the Grandmaster never enough
okay let's see how it goes whoa-ho-ho
what you guys sippin on well it's it's
definitely not beer max away was was a
true gentleman yes in the spirit of
Michael Tao Oh saga of Paul Karras yes I
do hope to do a Kara saga someday and
Bronstein saga someday and in the suruc
tournament Sunday but you know we'll
cover everything at one point we can
cover everything simultaneously
okay so Pappas is still in the lead
let's let's continue that let's see if
you can take on the penguin penguin
almost almost on 3000 rating
the message healthful review hahaha yeah
it's a good it's a good thing that
message was helpful review World
Championship matches well those are
those are there forever we always have
enough time to cover the cover that ah
they say Papas is a well-known Greek
streamer okay I seem to have been living
you know in a forest or how did they set
under a rock so I don't know pop ah see
ah but I will definitely check it out if
any of you guys have more information
you know do do share in the comments no
it's it's it's definitely not beer so
you know what what is they say Allah
Reza in Zubov are the only one that can
stop penguin but I don't know Pappas he
seems to be doing quite well yeah so
okay so he's a pretty famous Greek
streamer hibachi okay yeah he is indeed
yeah and okay
here's the current score against the
penguin is forty four to ten sold so
yeah he's definitely not yeah I don't
know I think my Claire
I think like only Magnus has a positive
score against penguin whoa okay crazy
even if it's just for show it's a nice
smoke Queen agree like everything works
so did he capture anything I I didn't
feel 96 after this like after he
captures yeah but we can let's see if he
can just roll off no okay but the night
hangs huh thank you mister mister mister
paradise yawn can you tell us again the
English opening joke what
I think it's a joke from like the the to
2,000 subscribers at 200,000 subscribers
stream it was I think there was someone
mentioned that joke like do you want to
hear a joke
the English English that that became the
English opening joke that was so yeah so
yeah I heard that lately but not not
just lately but for a long time the
London opening is getting quite a heat
for being like like joking about it like
in a way that I mean I don't know why
but I guess okay I don't want to jump on
a bandwagon or something
but people are just like making fun of
it I don't know yeah was do you know
what's the reason
well I don't know all that many people
didn't make fun of it since everyone
plays it I know yeah yeah it always
makes fun of it but he also plays it but
Magnus also played it for sometimes the
London yeah ever everyone played the one
that's you have to play the one that
maybe that's why it became a joke I mean
Papa is doing really well here I got to
say I mean yeah I just I just never
think that someone will actually be
pinguin so yeah up until this point I
mean no still I still don't think that
okay no I mean Papa see it was doing
well up until this yeah I mean okay he
he does have a way of pushing those
pawns but I know I cannot stop them fun
yes but I don't know five seconds I
think five seconds is plenty for penguin
yeah I would be very surprised if
something other than that happens that
was a nice try but okay four seconds for
penguin and I don't think he's even
thinking about it now this is like the
matrix for him he doesn't even see the
numbers you know he just sees you know
brunettes blondes yes I mean oh okay
well bang one takes him down Wow nice
it's just
she was the situation so he was enough
it was the kitchen he's still in the
lead
okay so who that was that was intense
that was so high they say papasa is
lagging well that's that is this a shame
we have a we have a someone think Shiva
Mukesh of Zima well good for you we are
free sorry or two living there yeah it's
a nice town
yeah the Aten says have you seen the
Joker and the new Joker movie I have
seen it yeah did you enjoy it
well yes I did yes I enjoyed it as well
I was I actually I I didn't want to see
it because I thought it would be just
like a really bad movie but then I saw
it you know it was definitely
interesting like I remember at some
points it was like not quite my taste
but in overall I would say it's a really
good movie yeah so but yeah I heard that
there maybe are trying to like think of
me making the number - yeah I don't
think so - yeah no the Phoenix said that
he would enjoy a sequel but it doesn't
seem like a movie that would have a
sequel yeah well you know me I think it
would only ruin it I think black is
winning this how did you get to choose
this game well should the thrill is he
one of the leaders well they are so hero
was in top 10 oh okay okay so I just
wanted to mix it up a bit because we
have seen against from other peoples
okay that's that's interesting Wow yeah
that yes yeah no yeah nice just to show
a nice winning technique you know here
and there and yeah for now maybe just
wanna see the other people so not just
from top the join button is not working
in the link well there is no join button
in the link but there is a link you you
copy/paste that I imagine I don't know
if you can actually click on the link in
the description from from a livestream
let me be a little bit biased here and
chew
one of the prospects all right from
Croatia
all right well divide always looking
forward to see a creation in such she
lost a lot of reading he started with
2,900 yeah jerking so maybe he's just
warming up okay okay
I guess he's berserk in the other games
but here's looking good
I mean having this strong cones in the
center yeah he wants to push that c4 but
it's not gonna happen
yeah boy is right or it might mr.
sergeant
probably doesn't want to allow it from
Belize yeah okay having good players
from all around the world
yeah before the tournament we saw a lot
of people from Cuba they make Cuban
grandmasters that's it almost never
happens so yeah that is you jinxed him
that didn't go for being biased sorry my
bad so let's just not watch any of his
game and he'll be first I GMT the Raja
says what do you think about dings
stalemate against the visit yeah I
haven't seen the game yet but I know
I've seen the stalemate so I don't know
it's just really weird
it was weird watching dink playing
against nipple in the speed chess
championship just didn't feel like ding
ding is just this so penguin is losing a
queen okay
and getting checkmate okay okay so it
happens so we've seen it on this dream
okay
okay mister mine trapper takes down the
penguin it's the first loss for penguin
is it yeah oh nice I mean sorry
unexpected I would say yeah l/l okay
currency I remember I remember him from
previous streams okay let's see his game
he's playing against penguin now both
berserk in second and third place okay
there's gonna be good battle for 2007
yeah I do remember that did you play
against yes penguin actually lost that's
okay
oh look at this course sixty seven
thirty
that's not bad is it that's a good score
that's a good score the beer is very
good thank you yeah yeah it's it's a
nice beer very good cold from the fridge
yeah it's a long stream so yeah gotta be
prepared whisper passive no I don't know
his name but well I've seen some people
writing it in the in the comments like
as the things have been going up until
now I guess we will remember him for the
next streams
yeah and should I should definitely
check out more more of the other
streamers some two years ago I knew
everyone who was dreaming but now they
were like I don't know 20 streamers two
years ago now there are maybe 200
streamers
oh so it's it's impossible to check out
everyone I mean only chess alone or know
I like general okay okay penguin is
starting to think for more than a 5
seconds so yeah I know that Anand Anand
and the Crossan started the cricket game
today against India against Bangladesh
they rang the bell for the start really
yeah okay nice yeah
Markus was like this when he rang well
like this yeah yeah like a true bell
ringer will it a job or give his
candidate spot to MDL I would be very
very surprised Alexandra's papacy Marco
Polo's Alexander's Papa Simic applause I
read every times that is a Greek but Oh
Oh penguin went with an ice queen h2 and
took the Queen okay
that's a pro move boss is still in the
lead he's just what he's the fastest
four points in front of super fast
berserk in some games I get oh okay
there's a new GM in top ten let's just
check justice ah da if we just follow it
no I guess he's just waiting
yeah oh okay also one of those Cuba
one of the spoken grandmasters from Cuba
yes Mac weeds we we do see your comments
okay have I heard any news about half
month Alexandre Houseman no I haven't
heard any the recent news about him
what's up with mister no I don't know
okay
the someone just asked if I heard any
recent news about how this month okay
how to light chat yes but mostly is
definitely on fire yeah I mean being in
first place for quite a long time now
yeah that's pretty good
you want to see a nice photo of of
chalky off off even Chuck hmm well I do
have one but maybe even two but I don't
know I I took my thinkers the avocadoes
book through it to my other space where
I sometimes go so I don't have it here
outer space where just some time ago
yeah interesting mysterious Oh Papa see
is they say 23 73 Blitz rated oh so he
is doing quite well what herb Dominic
positive is Osaka okay what's people
from Croatia yeah
oh we have no Assad here okay
yon bring back your YouTube my YouTube
well young YouTube for for you know
greater things in life yeah trying to
find myself you know you know how it is
and and hiking hiking yeah trying to
soar to higher Heights
yeah Phillip Phillip Croatia asks where
where I'm from we are we are both from
cleared see if you can pronounce that
then you are probably not all that far
away from us and that just by
pronouncing that it gives you a few
rating pop yeah yeah that does new
t-they rule so just try it yeah I would
I would love to come to India but far
away yeah well I mean if you're on a
plane doesn't really matter
yeah sure although now that we went to
Germany two weeks ago and well they had
Lufthansa had a strike and then we just
got strapped oh okay yeah so we had to
take the train which wasn't all that bad
but you know still took us like an
entire day to reach our destination
instead of like half an hour so just
that airline had a strike
yeah but only that airline was flying to
where we were going know what's going
there yeah okay enough oh I know
spoken like a true German have we have
we written the manga yes no not yet it's
you know it's it's it's a process you
know you don't just write a manga yeah
so I don't know maybe maybe two three
months give or take I will see how it
goes
I can pronounce Chris Ravi yeah almost
is the penguin Magnus no is Magnus the
penguin penguin many questions okay
that's uh yeah I don't know how how is
he allowed to spam it like that it
shouldn't be possible like copy paste
it's like multiple times in a row
ah okay yeah I don't have any any mods
for my stream but I never have any mods
for my stream so it's not oh it's lunch
wow he has one pawn and he wanted yes
that's it one point is all it takes for
a guy from Cuba yeah which all the tags
yeah one point Wow oh but she lost the
first place now we have a joint lead
between the knight should I ever die
should I have still a streak yeah we and
he Quezada also without a loss oh but he
joined maybe a little bit later or not
berserk oh and
is also yeah having a nice streak so
should I've earned himself oh yeah go
string I'll go dive and have we lost all
the Raisa yeah he's not in the top ten
oh he left I don't know would be strange
maybe he got mad that the tournament
broke down no I don't think that's
enough to get him mad but maybe we can
search for him just to see if he's
playing of course can you visit us if
you visit Croatia next week yeah sure
you just contact Eon and then we're all
gonna have a nice nice beer exactly
that's how we roll my number is okay
playing against the feet of Master Jean
McConnell oh also Oh from Kazakhstan
okay battling it out it's nice for sure
okay
will it be yes he keeps the outside pawn
v2 goes away of course but why ah he's
going for Knight f6 at some point and
now the rooks are going on the second
ranked no.1 is yeah they can capture and
play King g7 rooks yeah the light-square
bishop has to join somehow like maybe
bishop h3 36 for some peculiar reason
mm-hmm you know yeah it is bullet after
all yeah we might we might see this you
can play it to win it comes to test yeah
or better Bishop f1 to b5 to see signal
to lock down that but yeah that's all
gone can you check the King can still go
on g7 okay no no it's a now it's
dangerous oh and you like now Bishop h3
cover c8 or when our Bishop h3 is deadly
wasn't mr. Page three deadly No
captured I can just get through Wow
always good just capturing it so how
will he do it okay I mean I think that
at this point the black can just push
the pawn right you can capture on d6 go
the Queen no yeah Bishop g7 works even
if after yeah
Queenie five and the king can go away so
huh Bishop g7 or just blah yeah what why
ah yeah we're good like we Nia Wow
impressive impressive and beautiful very
good very good game okay
but he lost the first place Knight King
is bruiser king yeah and going for that
first place but bossy and third mutt bro
also familiar from yeah mother always
always in every stream so let's check
out this yeah
we cannot castle with beers since these
are not beers no these are parties what
did you give me they're not not beers
it's a not beer it's not be okay it's a
new kind of beverage okay
very tasty yeah it reminds me of a
certain trait that it's not a beer okay
let's see mad pro having a nice position
oh the h-bomb is missing how strange
yeah I was it uh no it wasn't no I
thought it was a bishop sacrifice but it
wasn't it doesn't seem like it yeah
Queens you serve probably but yeah then
you just movie Queen important Rakesh
Reno oh wait up Trey nitrate or f6 and
no Nate century and still remember some
stuff yeah what fro is unfortunate yeah
okay okay but yeah it was a 1800 player
he played against an 1800 player did
yeah okay
what's strange together you just hover
over his name hover over his name click
him like a little left clicking okay now
you have it see Oh 1818 Ford really yeah
really impressive from the first ok ok
night King takes believe but should I
have still without a loss and ended up
making lost the last game so ok but
let's see what do we have here we all
these back more oddly yeah you're
banging more oddly of course because
after all he is in first and haven't
seen his game okay it's not titled
what's the country after by John Houser
by John yeah playing against Montreux ok
well for the second time
ok mud Pro reaches 2900 very nice ok
what's that suppose I know is not okay
John is persistent yeah John is uh I
don't think how is it okay if we if we
get so much spamming
we have to time someone out okay
what do you mean time someone well
you're not about to spam if you spend
too much then you give someone a timeout
five minutes then he can't type anything
for five minutes but you do it manually
yeah you do it manually but mostly when
you have a stream where you have like
3,000 viewers you should appoint mods
and they should you know to watch out
for things like that okay but I forgot
to do that okay but mr. Cena says please
make me a mod so he's obviously
listening what we're talking about so
okay you are now a mod he said please
get them out I was gonna mod ok so is
everyone interested in being a mod for
this stream just yeah like someone who
has high moral values you know it's
possible for great people to have great
responsibility
yeah like spider-man do I think better
Peter Lego is underrated
no I think Peter Lacko is one of the
strongest players even today yeah
definitely not overrated or underrated
okay yeah he says I'm gonna mod me I'm
very moral okay now I kind of doubt the
depth you are without people that think
too much of themselves ya know well okay
if if we will require a mod I will add
one but I don't on okay so the current
situation is pretty much the same
situation in top 10 yeah you can go back
but we have JMC wand and RG 3 g6 like a
g6 also a new player but i would like to
see you okay go further let's see ya all
the res is still playing all eyes are
still playing in top 10 but okay alone
is also here and let's go here and try
to maybe motivate someone okay to get
there I remember territory I think plays
in in every tournament okay 900
a guy from Peru a place Queen to c3 why
not okay with a bishop there I would
check okay yes I guess he wants to
Roberto b6 rook c8 yeah maybe playing a
guys who needs teaching okay okay let me
check let me check if if I have a nice
one or if what do you need Oh a bunch of
photo or what was it okay we just
correct me they say that the Magnus did
play on leeches since the merger twice
okay in title arena in September and the
numerous tournaments for his club offers
Pele so there's that okay yeah I thought
he didn't but seems like he did okay
good for him not a problem
okay let's let's see all right okay
Terry is doing pretty I should always
have some
photos of even shook prepared their girl
when I have a stream like me printed out
Terry just won again for people to enjoy
all okay here's a nice photo of young
Vassili I do have it okay there you go
look at him look at that
so are a bunch of photos in high demand
yes they are okay as many as possible
okay but don't get you know greedy okay
that was one we'll have another one
another one soon so back to top ten
chewed i've-i've is still unbeaten with
a rating of 2,700 so I'm really
interested in seeing how I mean here's
also you know what like 10 20 games
undefeated that's that's quite a lot
maybe not 20 but 10 to 15 at least okay
still still very impressive yeah and he
will have like a winning position here
in a rockin game he'll capture the pawn
on a seven and then quickly just bring
up the quick the King yeah so yeah very
good fortune dive our Ganesha photos no
I asked I asked Nikki Nikki said that I
asked her why wait doesn't she take more
photos of Grichuk now that he was
playing he won defeated Grand Prix she
said that if she takes one photo as soon
as she can but he just plays so fast he
makes a move and then he just rolls
around he never sits down that's very
hard to get good photos of grisha but
you know that that's why when you see
before Greece shook you should you know
cherish it okay guess he's not doesn't
just sit around at the board he he just
he throws around t-shirts look like
tabloid covers thank you
yes I was
we were like commenting on there your
you know your ad could be here will be
here in case you didn't notice how many
subscribers Marquez
it's all over here
yeah maybe a bit too large but yeah okay
so the current situation is white is
still okay one to two seconds
Oh give up a queen what no it was a
sneaky attempt but Elm okay
let's say 2007 let's go back to the
tournament one beaten nikolaich arrived
so that is nikolai for the win
okay so we have j MC and re 22 okay
those are the new guys in top 10 yeah oh
and federico okay haven't seen him so
let's check out his game no it's always
uh you know i don't think we were having
any cheaters here but you never know I
mean when you put forty rated games I
think you yeah yeah but I pretty much oh
yeah since the you know if they joined
the tournament that we announced three
days ago didn't they could have easily
made 40 games but this is a new element
so I don't know we'll see we'll see what
leeches Steven Mendoza says how many
subscribers do you have well me no no I
think he's just making fun of us for
having big signs on our t-shirts okay in
our defense we did not design the
t-shirts yeah yeah that is true we just
wear them we're just models okay makes
me a mod I'm very nice and I think
Russia is cool too okay those are you
know good criteria for being a mod you
have to think Russia is cool I would
search that in a mod yeah like okay you
have some skills button do you think
rock high school additional requirement
here do you know what omoro say which is
doing besides chess now mr. mike says no
I do not know I know he's commenting on
chest but other than that probably yeah
it would be a shame if he was doing
something else but I mean not mine he
should only be doing chest of course
exciting player yeah sure
probably takes long walks like to relax
well says the Grisha takes 45 minutes
for move eight plenty of time together
phone yeah but maybe he strolls around
for those 45 minutes you know yeah like
he throws around what do I play and move
eight it's just a power play
yeah I think it's just you know psyching
out his opponents okay James see from
the Dominican Republic
LSR your comment has been read sir thank
you mr. Uday okay that was a quick one
oh that was a quick one so IG three
beats
GMC one yeah okay there's that two guys
from top ten and now we have seen all
the games from the guys from top ten
okay
takes the lead ahi berserks that's why
he takes the lead and should I have is
taking it slow he does not berserk but
he doesn't lose okay so let's I am for a
little bit of a more exciting games I'm
not saying that
Jaedong games aren't exciting but if you
berserk
well yeah you just earned a little bit
more yes all the preference here so
here's berserk against onyx 23 who's
currently are both Burger King both yeah
both are Burger King
so and in 902 versus 2500 and the mom is
having a nice position so far so it is
the queen man game is gonna be cool hard
to win so okay
it could be a sneaky queen taking
attempts okay yeah of course Queen d4
you don't want to go to d4 no like at
this point is really you don't know what
yes in 8 seconds yeah I think Mac Pro is
just checking and he I think he's just
making sure
oh the not check twice on the same
square that's all he's in the square
okay okay he's okay oh I think he should
have played with the king but what
FLAC could have taken the pawn yeah I
mean okay yeah it's I think he was more
flying yeah he was uh making sure he
Flags nicely rather than then playing
the the correct move we're almost
approaching the halftime of the
tournament with one hour and ten who did
night King clues to how can I check that
oh just play yeah just click on let's
play so lost to Federer Martinez yeah
and Grandmaster Monte Martinez no I
meant the first game yeah oh and the
first game out first I saw the zero ok
ok and Federico who did he lose against
Aris and where is the Rebecca Harris
he was just she he she he know it first
and probably yeah it makes sense now
there is also here
Levi's doing incredibly well researching
yeah he is so I guess that earns him
yeah that's why a spot yeah you're on
the stream careful not to jinx him yeah
once again
yeah it's playing as Watchers yeah a
frequent participant
I think Vova also won one of the three
spots in one of my tournaments but think
of mr. Charles from Sweden okay oh yeah
unfortunately lemon is down a pawn in
the same game and let's see how Bobo
just manages okay and he's very long
time so I don't think that's possible
yeah okay you never know yeah I prefer
playing with the wooden pieces more than
plastic waited once yeah that's a pawn
on f4 and yeah is it once again my fault
I think so yeah he's just gonna grab
that form
yeah he's not gonna grab the point okay
it does make her sweat okay so as we
said before no here's games wish him
luck okay we yes okay that's that does
look like you know if I was a cheater
that I would have that nickname you know
okay nothing anything
if you're not a cheery yeah either
apology yeah but a good name for a
cheater he ever the list like V V V V s
let's see how he goes against Rebecca
carrots first so okay like also not okay
that's Queen captures right no or even
that okay so there is a clear path to
maybe checkmating even I don't know okay
rogue d8 yeah the queen is lost Rebecca
Harris for the great style there but we
are not not resigning the game still
it's okay
why not resign this well you enjoy
playing chess okay okay but even in lost
positions you know you say why not
no let's just see what happens push the
pawn okay it's it's a nice position
actually okay you're not pushing it
anywhere else
yeah Harris is a man Rebecca Harris is a
man so that was also my question so you
know who it is yeah I just can't
remember the name Daniel
oh maybe someone from the yeah I mean I
am I know the name I just I just can't
remember I also remember him from the
last room Harris is I'm sure someone
will write it now Daniel never did yeah
okay very very strong Claire no I've
never been in Switzerland
have you been to Switzerland no no I've
been to the Alps
almost almost you've seen with Rowley
yeah
far away nice country yeah snowy you
gotta say oh nice nice happen on G to
nothing okay for now so my guess is
black is going to win but yeah but the
wife is really legislating
both of their time I would say you know
it's it's his prerogative okay so he can
do what he wants no people people
thought the middle died but he was just
sleeping yeah that's what happens yeah
Queens you to check Mele everybody dude
yeah laziness or death
pretty close okay so nice doing doing
nicely nothing is quite okay with 70
points on top
Jadhav still without without a defeat in
second place see this is you know
without a defeat and not in first place
that's how much berserk ink you know
will get you okay so I'm gonna let's
just see his game
so again against each me I know it's
their first game I thought they already
played once but we saw doesn't seem so
game with teach me why do I always say
sorry about that in the beginning of
every video well I do have to fix the
sound you know so it's perfect because I
need the sound I need to hear the sound
when I make the mousse it just you know
it's very soothing if it helps me know
that I actually made a move but I don't
want it to be too out so there's no
double sound okay you know if you hear
the sound through my speakers and also
through the software so I know it's it's
a weird at some point but you know I
don't mind it being weird if it improves
the sound quality very nice explanation
yeah yeah Yan do you prefer or Driscoll
or Carla Carla watch called away I don't
know I don't even know how this is even
a question here to somebody I don't want
to offend anyone but Carla watch oh come
on
yeah I'm not a fan of either okay yeah
but if I have to choose so we are
drinking non beer or not beer today yeah
these are not bears not bears but if I
gotta choose between
orders concur logic car let's go all the
way yeah when a job of or manager of
become world champions I should make a
video and title it do it the legendary I
didn't read it
all the way but yeah definitely someone
asked if he for a job okay aha
the legendary Azerbaijan as someone
mentioned before a job will give his
place in the candidates mvl I don't see
that happening even if mommy even if
you're a Java isn't all that interested
in actually playing the candidates which
would be a first I believe okay ever -
you know qualify for candidates and to
not play it I don't know I guess
anything is possible but I don't see it
having okay should I going for the
checkmate here okay and once again
winning the game so what is happening
here so should I have still unbeaten but
still not in the first place let's check
out the night yeah uh I'm still working
strong okay not Burger King anymore
okay so against Terry let's see here
Tata still is going on in my vicinity do
you know that well if I knew you were
very near the Tata Steel I would know
that yeah oh okay
squeaking chairs yeah really
that's the good chair this is the the
bad one I always get the good chair yeah
and this is the new boots chair I gave
the other good chair to you also
oh okay yeah I didn't think well no but
this one is not squeaky squeaky
no that's the t-shirt Amin's the
billboard sign yeah let's go it for what
it really is
yeah young how much would you charge you
know for some company to ask you young
would you wear our low
like that like I like like this big yeah
like that big maybe even bigger maybe
all the way no maybe a couple of nut
beers yeah that would be enough yeah
so what's the situation here knocking
not breaking this time yes you mention
against Terry are two and he actually
has a very nice score against him four
and a half to seven and a half yeah
and Terry r2 has bigger rating so no oh
he does Wow I'm interesting so what will
happen here so the knight can capture so
what am I missing
okay no no I'm the queen yeah sure but
you didn't have to take oh yeah because
of Queen d6 and Bishop e5 yeah yeah yeah
okay nice so nigh king wins beautiful so
I yeah it's probably yeah terry terry
has a higher rating because he may be
morrow gotta gotta see this okay that's
that's a nice streak okay nice best
Ramirez I'm penguin improved they are
fourth and fifth now we finally see a
clear picture of all title players in
top ten yeah I wonder if all the resin
and penguin and the other players will
simply continue with delicious titled
arena they'll be like really crazy place
chess for such a long time on such a
fair level
yeah thank you for the contribution sir
I didn't check who it was what okay
let's see mr. Kurt Kurt Wilms okay from
San Francisco California I think who a
friend of mine said today that that it's
it's really really expensive to live in
San Francisco like that I was assumed in
insanely expensive like like is it the
whole California or just Sanford LA he
he was specific about San Francisco okay
so you said you in the friend of yours
Mila said about a friend of his Wow okay
you're not clear in the picture
resolution is low
I shouldn't be stream health is medium
as it was maybe maybe just try you know
increasing the definition okay we have a
new player in top 10 he says you should
try living in Norway oh yeah no thank
you i I think it would be too cold for
my taste maybe just in the summer time
yeah yeah they say all of California is
expensive but senator San Francisco is
double that
oh okay somebody matches the pretty
that's a good point yes over there okay
second most expensive after or Manhattan
okay yeah okay you have like really poor
people there and like incredibly rich
people there so not when I'll be
searching for a place to live so go San
Francisco yeah although there's the song
you know you should go to San Francisco
with a flower in your hair what I'm
gonna sleep in the van yeah I don't
think that that flies anymore okay we
have a nice situation between Munir and
jihad Fletcher says Dubrovnik is more
expensive okay maybe if you live there
yeah but I've been to Dubrovnik last
year and I don't know it seemed way
cheaper than if you like maybe three
years ago or five years ago I don't
think they're trying to rip off tourists
like they used to
so the funny thing is I mean for a for a
guy from Croatia like all the people
when you travel ask you about Dubrovnik
and I've never been there
yeah only once people always ask you
when you're from Croatia okay I've been
and they say I've been to Dubrovnik yeah
like that and I hate it when people say
yeah I've been to Croatia it's beautiful
yeah they say you've been to Dubrovnik
right yeah it's beautiful yeah I know
but is not Croatia I mean this one place
yeah it it could it could very well be a
separate country you know it it
basically has nothing to do with Croatia
I mean it's
yeah yeah okay we have one nice place
and yeah we don't want to get now we
have a lot of nice place no of course
yeah this one is you know just the most
famous ones because of game of choice we
wanted let's jig we wanted to check out
King's Landing and it's like I don't
know it's like 20 or 30 euros just the
climb you know oh and you have to do it
yourself the climb yeah and there were
too many people so they wouldn't even
accept the money for you know really so
you could walk around the King's Landing
yeah
it's it's too crowded I heard it was a
problem that you know the tourists Arun
is too much that they should lower the
the amount of people they allow in okay
but it's you know it's just something I
heard don't mark yeah I mean there are a
lot a lot of nice places in Croatia
yeah I've been taking up lots of hiking
lately
and you should see the especially the
Adriatic part during the summer but also
the mountain area summer and even like
this late it's very nice yeah there's
very nice country yeah you should come
here definitely not crazy maybe not live
here come and go away yeah yeah I yeah
yeah I actually went hiking once with
yawn but we didn't get very far
yeah that was a it was a good trip
yeah young bought a new car and then it
just stopped
yeah it happens you know
yeah even new cars break yeah yeah cars
are like that yeah okay should I've lost
a single game so far no and this is why
I'm giving it him another chance to use
my monster to embarrass himself a write
on the stream but he is doing pretty
well yes please with the plate itself
ready yeah I've been to please it's like
a hundred times since I
shorter weddings with my father for a
very long time and you know every
wedding couple who wanted to go to plead
with say yes for a photoshoot and then I
just visited it quite a lot
okay that's also the other place people
ask you about yeah something they visit
under way to Dubrovnik yeah we're going
down you know why not like but like I
was there a week ago okay and it was
raining heavily like so much that you
even couldn't walk around oh but it's
nice even when it rains but there was
still tourists that's what I wanted to
say you know yeah Thank You mr. Stephen
Mendoza I remember when we we used to
shoot weddings there
well not weddings but you know of photo
shoot couples well you know we had
decent equipment not like
state-of-the-art equipment but then you
had like I don't know some torque
tourists from Japan and all of their
equipment was better than Oracle what
happens you know okay yeah Austria Robin
also very nice
you gotta say like we're just promoting
Croatia yeah if you're a she should
definitely visit it yeah
Mike says that he played Korchnoi in
Zurich in in 2008 when he was 16 so
friendly Korchnoi friendly well I I
guess wasn't his age will do that to you
know what we're just yeah saying that we
want some more non beers yeah yeah not
beers no no no not beer all right sorry
it's not not be IR are it's it's you
know me I are it's not bit like like a
short I okay not ah thank you thank you
here you go thanks a nice cold not beer
[Music]
so eight behind I mean you mean AHA the
cupboard
you know never heard of a cover being
referred to as boxes before okay focus
more on the turn yeah no no we have it
we have we have five thousand people
focusing oh yeah so we've reached the
the number of people that was at the
start of the tournament when it crashed
so yeah there is that and Chad ever lost
the first game ah what is it nan beers
yeah I don't know good yeah well I don't
think we'll beat the previous tournament
but you never know so vs 99 haven't seen
this game guy from the states
yeah why not no we haven't had vs 99 as
of yet does anyone know what Nakamura's
burner account on leeches is what's a
burner account I guess it's like a
burner phone you use and you throw it
away
like you use it once oh okay could be
that think so
no yeah cousin Nakamura is not allowed
to play on leeches
I don't believe since he has a like a
contract with chess calm so are we
having a little bit of controversy here
why I like if we find out that Nakamura
explained oh yeah I don't think so how
would we even how do we even find out
and I will just ask someone from the
states in the chat are you Nakamura are
they say burner account is a troll
account Oh
a troll okay yeah but what is the troll
account I mean what what does it mean I
guess you beat 20 grand masters and no
one
those who are offline who is offline we
are really I mean it says here okay we
are live now that's a very strange we'll
see what happens with the the amount of
people watching yeah just just a quick
check it it just said that the stream is
offline so if anyone could confirm is
the stream actually online meadow is
here maybe he's just chillin
he's just chillin yeah yeah okay yeah
you use a you use that account not to
reveal who you are okay can you talk
about a less popular places to visit in
Croatia well we could talk about them
yes but will we like if you ask me now
what is the least popular place to visit
in croatia i don't know what what I
would say like like no place is that bad
I mean you could have fun anywhere I
guess I like even you can come to our
town yeah okay you don't really have a
lot to do here like exactly you could
have a beer or two or maybe 12 or well
we do have a very nice craft beer no
nowadays yeah basically the our town is
famous for the amount of bars and
churches not for not libraries we only
have one one library but bars and
churches we do have a lot of churches
yes yeah and of course bars but it's
like yeah tom says it well we have a
rakia everywhere that is true yes so in
Croatia you can go wrong yeah just a sip
of raki and you have yeah everywhere
sometimes I'll just walk around the city
you know with the rakia and I'll just
ask someone hey man
do you want some rock and see like no I
have my own it's cool but we could drink
together
yeah let's celebrate this day hey Marcus
guys very nice mocker skies a beautiful
yeah Vinton Marcus go yeah I was there
last year as well maybe maybe even this
year no last year no this year I've been
this year I've been last year it's uh
it's a very nice place and it's also
like this very beautiful site where you
can see like you'd have seaside and
there is like it's very very high
mountain which is almost it's like 750
is the highest peak I know you went
there for hiking
no I didn't go for hiking this time I
was going with a car but it's still like
a very nice view you can see like the
whole okay like the islands in front
it's very nice view so and you can walk
a lot I know we walked like I know
what's that in but I had my phone my
phone told me that we made like over
20,000 steps in an evening so that was a
very impressive for me because I don't
don't walk around a lot good yeah but we
only when only did one lap around like
the the main part so it was really
really enjoyable okay yes the game thank
you mister she she wanted re from India
penguin takes the first place okay he's
$29.99 should've started losing games
okay
okay he lost two games so far okay he
said these guys are saying I'm winning
all the games lose some yeah more oddly
who is Murad Lee and who is I will rock
you 73 73 from Argentina or was it or
was it no that marketer Federico was
from okay and Murad Lee is from
Azerbaijan I think we saw his game but I
wanna see Penguins game because he has
eight points oh okay we have a
congratulations from chess calm my
comfort for joining the chat
cheers Cheers okay I still have this one
okay oh you take it off yeah I think you
know I don't know it's just weird
and also no one else takes it all so I
always know which is not very smart that
is very clever
good life hack yeah thank you just calm
very nice of you to join no idea who it
is who runs the new YouTube account from
I'm sure that comes part but pretty sure
is like it's like Danny wrench or
someone anyone but yeah could be could
be could be yeah yeah is it is it
Kolkata or Kolkata I don't know since I
pronounce Kolkata in my videos today in
India the city in India
yeah and everyone not everyone ought
don't English say Kolkata yeah I don't
know I'm interested how do they
pronounce it over there oh well penguin
is now in 13-point lead okay so he's on
he's on a row okay 45 minutes still to
go in the tournament so don't get
discouraged I'm okay watching all there
is like he's in fifth place
maybe preparing more for the main
tournament not main terminal delicious
style arena here we come
let's check out rocky rocky someone asks
that you're kind of pronouncing it wrong
yeah okay I realized that it's called
Kolkata yeah I don't think I'll yeah
I'll just ask someone to explain it to
me since I will be covering the
tournament for send the videos the few
days send the video pronouncing yeah
okay I'll check out the video from
Charlotte shot from Jay's base India he
probably said Kolkata at some point of
the video just check out how he does it
okay black so I will rock you has a very
nice position here okay I mean
just one a night is a nice position
and his opponent resigned so I guess
keeping the place in life is a night
like it's very very crowded from the
second place up until 2/7 even eighth
and ninth place and difference is very
small here with four points but penguin
is in front berserk in all the games
yeah with a 13 point lead so yeah and
like for now maybe just to take a little
break from the top ten because it's
still maybe a few times go back okay
let's say maybe someone is on a roll so
like this guy me yeah like this guy like
he is winning all the games and now it's
time to show him on the stream okay
from Iran yeah let's see oh there's
international master shot yeah I'm gonna
go with chocolate or it could be just
schmuck schmuck come on that's a very
strong powerful name Matt my name is
Matt yeah gotta be scared before playing
the game can we watch a match of Eric
Rosen yeah if we were yeah I saw every
crossing register for the first
tournament that just didn't seem in the
in the second tournament we just created
okay yeah we'll definitely check out a
game you're sure so if that's what the
people want if you have like any other
people that you want to see a game of
yeah but for now here we have a pretty
equal game I would say yeah okay guys
just don't spam in the chat like okay
maybe you can copy paste several times
but not like all the time we're gonna
have to do some time lapse or we're
gonna we're really points on mods yeah
somebody wants to say game for mother is
oh yeah definitely the favorite we've
already seen a lot of them
but okay black is king white well yeah
someone said could you add Kashima photo
to my channel wall yeah Booga regime of
would definitely grace the the photo of
my channel wall but so III have to add a
lot of other players as well so as I'm a
terrible designer I mean you've seen how
much he looks so I I don't I don't want
to design it myself
and well if any of you would like to
design it feel free to contact me on my
email is like if anyone else would like
to do the work yeah I mean I the problem
is I like my design is just that no one
no one else does you know oh so it's not
a problem for me I actually enjoy whoa
he just yeah we know that shock mat
means checkmate it's it's Universal and
it's also in creations yeah bring the
weekly streams back yeah I I always say
I'm gonna bring the weekly streams back
but I don't know it always just I do too
much videos I think to bring the weekly
streams back at some point I do hope to
rectify this okay Mott is yeah I mean
the men who are mad the guys who he
started to watch he is going to continue
his tricky as far as I can see should be
waiting for black yeah I mean playing be
to okay start pushing tones what now
interesting what now let's just see what
happens see if you study the endgame you
would know yeah whoa no no okay no he
just he lost
what insane insane that's what happens
yeah he didn't wanna draw and he'll
capture with check on geez ah you jinxed
him dude he was doing so well my bed
okay Eric Rosen can we uh yeah I think
you can search and you're gonna type it
okay
so helpful this guy okay okay let's
let's see if Eric is doing well yeah
okay
43 he is not bad not bad let's see how
Eric is doing so we caught him up like
almost at the beginning of the game
playing against Lisa Lisa's there yeah
almost yeah what's that like polish or
polish I don't know like I see a I see a
C in the Z maybe you know like a like an
S maybe with a D a Romanian yeah let's
see who was closer a game where white
you're right yeah Bowen okay you see a
Sienna ZZZ
yeah okay I guess two rooks G to H one
for broken a bishop and should be okay
c7 yeah I can't defend the pawn okay
captured captured oh okay oh but what
happens after what okay thank you mr.
Raja Rama Rama such a great entertainer
well thank you sir I do my best
like I'm not trying to entertain today I
do my best
you know every day this is just you know
we organized a tournament were a lot of
very very capable players do their best
and we just enjoy the show so this is a
day where we are the ones enjoying the
show and it's very nice we indeed do yes
it's just I don't know it's just
something very refreshing when you put a
lot of strong players and you make them
play bullet
it's just the best yeah okay this is not
this is 2 plus Oh
so I would prefer one claw so it would
be like true adrenaline rush but it's
it's better for you know since we do so
much common thing that it's 2 plus so
I'm just commenting so much expertise
yeah you know look at the end game yeah
I can see it play it out but okay why
this hanging quite well here I mean
having a lot of pawns even though being
a rock down but he is down on time yeah
that's a lot of points and in in in
bullet form the glue matter keep the
Queen always keep the Queen okay white
wins this oh definitely
Erik for the win okay at least we didn't
jinx Erik know Erik is black huh
everything's black
yeah oh isn't Erik white oh man
oh but it's gonna be a battle of thank
you thank you mr. Kurt what at least a
draw let's know can he can he do it okay
now if you can't do it good with a queen
yeah but it's wow yeah difficult man I
mean not all of us play hyper blood like
you
yeah I like when it's this close it's
also if you have a minimum lag you will
not be able to pre move it all the way
all the resin first place okay what
happened when we so we watch one game
from Derrick Rose okay that's not
strange that's totally expected right
the penguin had like 15 points in the
lead yeah but he lost two games most
likely to Alireza
if you want to click around him click
click on the penguin ah later on until
it is oh the guy from christened is he
anywhere near the top 10 live H should
be Oh 18 okay but very close very close
yeah he finishes games in
like ten moves awesome Munir okay they
say Papa see all Gaga but Papa joined
yeah yeah they were having oh yeah if
it's pop gr enough that golf up yeah but
it is if it's from Hungary yeah okay
let's let's see a guy who has first guy
who has a hundred points in the
tournament Olli Reza I'm still still
rated thirty one hundred so totally not
a problem playing against an unrated I
will rock you yeah someone asked someone
asked if I uh what was my opinion of
Antone horrible in his play well I
always say whenever you have an
opportunity to watch again by Anton
Caribe off you definitely check it out
the dead guy is just amazing you know
every game is just so so interesting and
he he meets a lot of a lot of top
players and it was very funny because in
in rapid event every you know including
myself I also said that he was the
lowest rated player and he was the
lowest rated player but he was the
highest rated rapid player so everyone
was amazed how he was just destroying
everyone he's just that strong all the
rest just lost a piece but it did he
lose a game no he didn't but he has 20
seconds of what this g6 no yeah okay you
know now he's down a whole rook almost
yeah and now he what oh wow what you see
it's insane
yes yes indeed getting some science from
the people over there yeah I think
there's a holidays I threw in the towel
okay
doesn't mean he loses the first place
yes and I'm saying when penguin is back
okay so now it starts to become
interesting I don't know all there is
I've had 100 points as far as I've seen
and now he has 95 yeah I don't know what
so we'll see if you lose the game you
lose points is that or maybe he won
against the cheater and the cheater got
eliminated from determined and he lost
points you want
against the cheater which would be crazy
but you know one against a cheater
yeah yeah right it is possible okay it
is indeed and then what kind of a
cheater are you got it
well bank with penguin defeated Leela in
bullet and Leela was like thirty three
hundred at that point wandered the Queen
okay no could happen maybe they're
cheating with Leela but a Jawa height
Pakistan opinion and sucker thought took
a third amazing player amazing it was
really when I was in London this time
yeah but no when I was in London I went
to the bar the I can't remember the bars
name but you know yeah we had a
get-together there I said I will be
there and if someone wanted to come they
could you know come have a beer or
something and it was actually the bar
where two killer died he actually died
there playing chess really yeah and you
have before there there was the
chessboard where you know all the
players who ever played there and it was
the I don't know I guess the main
gathering ground for players in London
strong player so you have had everyone
thing there Paul Morphy played there
like Steinitz played there last we
played there a lot of people played
there okay and you had the engravings on
the board whoever who played on that
board it was on the wall you know I
posted it I think on Twitter and
Instagram but it was just really really
awesome yeah I didn't know it sort of
died there I was having a conversation
with a gentleman and I was reading all
the players that played there and he
said yeah that's died here all right
over to dead bar you want to get a drink
I'm looking new okay I just want to
focus attention to this game so I wanted
to see the game from always honorable
and Elmo had zero point something second
yeah but he drew up what but sumo head
like three or four six okay look man one
is streaming every
that's what I like to see I mean people
yeah
even our friend yeah even via KHOU
streaming vehicle Jeremy so is he
playing alright don't worry yes do we
wanna check it out yeah let's check on
vehicle game oh it's okay okay let's see
where is the vehicle that not too bad
Viacom Malfoy okay let's see how he's
doing okay is he playing okay somebody
is playing with his account if he was
hacked he does have a queen against two
bishops and rook so an interesting
position I'd take two bishops and the
rook yeah me too but okay okay
interesting
now how do you deal with that Wow nice
what's fast enough that's fast you know
if you want to go to c6 yeah maybe
yeah but the vehicle will try to flag
him dirty dirty style what what what but
he could have captured on the 200 c6
okay what vehicle will flag him yeah
okay what sticks in okay capture vehicle
capture nobody captures here just play
and yes hello to India so Rebecca Harris
in first place 19 second non-resident
third and a penguin in the fourth Oh
things started yeah we're definitely
okay people are saying that we should
timeout some people so yes it's the not
the checkmate bar but yeah now for the
second time if any is since this stream
will go on for at least three more hours
who is interested in being the mod and
now seriously guys only those of you who
with incredibly high moral values
you know do apply yes it's the Knights
bar yes it's a nice bar yeah Simpsons in
the Strand the nice bar yeah okay so
only you are the tournament director now
I just wanted to focus attention to this
ok ok ok very important announcement yes
ok sorry let me just okay I saw a person
who applied for a mod who's been a
subscriber here since like three years
ago
so ok mister how do you pronounce that
address address ich cafe you are you are
now a the first mod ad moderator all
right amazing so let me just open up
again so we have one mod now we'll see
how it goes if more will be needed we
will add more mods that's a moss that's
not ok ok let's just also click here
yeah the current situation and ok really
thankful for the mod duties and
everything yeah I saw a pregnant man
that was also in the tournament but we
haven't seen him as a as yet so we're
gonna search for him I don't know if
he's playing so what is his handle and
we still haven't figured is it a protein
Ananda or froggy Ananda like someone
said in the comments but I think they
would they would correct me a long long
time ago if it was actually that how do
you know if mod is doing a good job or
not well yeah ok but is enough that's
the question
well for for 2500 people I think more
yeah yeah alright mr. professor gamer if
if more mods will be needed you will be
definitely taking into
raishin who do you think who do you
think someone asked in the comments who
do you think is stronger
Anand or giddy like primes or errantly
now like I don't want to what I know
I mean honestly don't wanna offend
aren't in any way so I'm gonna see I'm
gonna go for Anand I don't want to go
here sorry no I don't want to find
myself in a situation with no offense to
Giri but you know like more like ena in
a bullet match what do you think would
win in the bullet match yeah like on the
leeches yes maybe I'm leeches I would
okay yeah it got me there I would say
I'm stopped because ha why did the
stream stop okay yeah that also happened
a couple of yeah it's back refresh or
ago hmm maybe we should refresh let me
let me just check something okay I'm
gonna go and choose another game let's
check Penguins game yeah the the stream
health seems to be low for some reason
we are not doing anything
so should we bash the internet providers
like we do every stream yeah it's you
know just put it on them let me just
check maybe something is doing something
in the background but I did restart the
okay some people say it was a drop but I
hope everything is fine now yeah it was
it robbed but now the string health is
back on so it's perfectly fine now
yeah yeah seems to be working nice oh
and there's a nice penguin ask you what
what is this what is what please explain
what is this flag this 3030 yeah it's
like like a whale on it
penguin Olin tardy yeah yeah you never
knew that okay the guy is funny as well
yeah because I guess he has a lot going
for him they say it was only five
seconds although I don't know if I yeah
it says elapsed time two hours so we the
stream has been going on for two hours
so it's not a problem I thought it would
be like this is only part of the stream
and then you know Flav Antartica is the
shape one time yeah okay is it really I
guess oddly so that's supposed to be I
would say that's a rhinoceros first okay
I've known it was the rhinoceros but
there aren't any Antarctica I thought it
was maybe a whale okay so do you think
it's it's actually the shape of
Antarctica yeah I'm gonna go with ya
home enter over here and say yes I mean
I don't know and loses night King takes
penguin so people were correct they said
this will be a tournament between
penguin Alvarez and Rebecca Harris but
we also have Bob sure dive and night
King okay so that's like yeah but pop G
gobble pop destroying everyone I think
he deserved definitely late he joined
late for sure yeah
so you might wonder what will happen if
he joined at the beginning but oh and C
4 B 5 now no against the titled wolf it
oh it's title that I thought maybe was
tilted but it's actually titled like a
hello from Albania is there like a wolf
cool box and like goes to the side old
side yeah like I'm so tilted
who is night king we actually make
hunting really hard yeah
who is night king we already solved that
did we yes because I think he also won
one of the one of the top three places
in one of my tournaments and but maybe
he wasn't I mean we found out who
Rebecca Harris is but yeah 96 yes yeah
it's just in a in a style of a tilted
wolf yeah okay what's that that's like
no I meant to d5 yeah okay so oh look
it's Alexander botanique not that we
need a botany or however it's pronounced
[Music]
the interface is not quite as usual no
the interface is not quite unusual since
I haven't streamed for a while well why
I haven't streamed since the previous
stream since April yeah since the 400k
arena and it seems leeches did something
with their interface so now it's just
you know appears different in my
interface so I think that's pretty much
it
haven't changed anything I think is made
or yes just playing in the back have I
played the dodge defense yes I do
I do enjoy an occasional Dutch defense
maybe like maybe the the stone wall I do
enjoy the stone wall okay why so the
title wolf is trying to win this game
but and as well he should like on g7 now
it's about time to just grab two times
yeah and that's it Wow okay mr. pop
resigned so we are who else are you
going to jinx I don't know just jinx
all the people here okay so we have we
have so many players streaming this is
this is insane yeah and I'm glad that
like now with 20 minutes to go we have a
very close tie I mean not the tie but
one point 109 108 all the res is closed
and Penguin dropped a little bit with
not having so good a couple of games
yeah it's a big difference in price fund
from from five to one yeah and more
oddly is still here and okay should they
have it even though he has been winning
a lot he okay trying to go back but yeah
a concentration girl can get you only
that far I guess yeah okay penguin back
in third let's check out Rebecca Harris
he is yeah the jinx inning sorry
the scats defense I don't know the scat
defense it's the Nam beer someone asked
if I would show a game where white loses
with the Evans gambit I would never do
that
yeah III would not do that does it even
exist
yeah I've seen heard people it's or to
you know it's a legend
the first official classical game I ever
played I played the Evans gambit oh yes
it was against and I was like 1600 and
my point was like 1620 and did you win
no it was a draw like a lose I think it
was the only Evans gambit draw ever yeah
I didn't lose yeah I mean if you know if
he played a little bit better I should
have lost but you know you just don't
lose with the Evans gambit that's that's
how it is I should play it
yes it's very you know rewarding okay
Rebecca Harris with a nice position okay
nice pass deep on extra check yeah
should be should be sufficient yeah
Oh before yeah I thought you would bring
the king they're not okay okay
it's very nice check hmm
bishop like a pond gotta be careful in
this games Oh will watching once again a
game from pub Jean yeah well okay now
he's up so much time
ah Harris berserk yeah and he's not down
so much time since he okay there should
be four and that's it yeah okay that's
the turn and that's the game
but okay so far in the lead yeah and on
fire Rebecca Harris only only player on
fire oh that one is in the top ten that
definitely deserves a place on the
stream so a little bit bodies that is
very impressive so the first two games
that I shows he has lost so looking
forward to again that he will win on the
stream kevin says have i thought about
making videos and openings i've have
thought about it but so far I haven't
decided on the format that I would enjoy
making it since there's so many there's
so much content on on YouTube and on
other platforms regarding openings I
would have to you know at least find
some way to contribute to that either by
figuring out a way where you can you
know just you know get more opening
knowledge in or just make it more fun or
contribute in some way but until that
happens we will not be having any
opening Theory videos maybe the maybe an
occasional Evans gambit or so what
occasional Evans yeah that's what people
really want to see yeah thank you mister
Ruben
oh okay
eleven I think now there's one exchanged
greetings from Serbia mr. Motta ch okay
okay okay oh no I thought it was King g7
this is my fault once again ah yeah
Levi lost but he also berserk and every
game okay so Rebecca Harris still in
first still on fire nineteen second
thing went really wild stuff wild stuff
15 minutes to go yes everyone has a
chance but we have a new player who
poses forces who is Passos he's playing
against Eric oh there you are once again
ok and yeah who is possibly responses
from from somewhere nowhere he's a
mysterious player mysterious mr. Passos
and nomads yeah oh I am the goat in
jinxing sorry
yeah I apologize to all the people but I
guess some people have won the game yeah
ok posters is definitely even though
he's not in exchange I guess he
shouldn't lose this game I would go
black here indefinitely
how did I find Germany my my plane took
me here yeah no it was a lovely lovely a
lovely country oh this roof on h4 isn't
going anywhere
yeah but I think I don't think black OH
for something like this route on edge
for really if that Bishop can come maybe
Bishop c4 to f1 or something yeah you
should be that could be very nice ok
what I mean Queen captures no okay no
black just wins
if he goes to a light we're okay he had
me yeah but he had a light we're okay oh
nice nice one checkmate
ah shame mr. Rosen yeah so I chose it
more important when we try and find
Prabhu is he still is he planed okay
let's see
nope no nope
sorry okay so I did see him join but
maybe he just didn't we just didn't find
the other the other tournament but still
Rebecca Harris now started berserk Inc
and I don't think going for the final
run yeah okay - finish it - finish nice
but see now we're going very close to
the end of the tournament twelve minutes
to go let's see playing against Maxime
shreds off yeah okay that is definitely
winning for white I would say with
rookie seven in the works
it's 12:30 in India 12:30 p.m. or am
nice and that is rook f8 No Oh beautiful
beautiful
undead game that's game now Rebecca here
is really nice and he wants you were
waiting for that win he's so much higher
rated like you'll be the 2,400 yes you
get zero reading I probably might be
sleeping they're saying because it's
late in India mmm
Oh loan is back at the top 10 okay what
can he reach top 5 maybe me that's 10
points in 10 but it's still very strong
yeah but if the top 5 you know keep
facing each other could happen could
happen
okay so Rebecca Harris I would like to
watch another game even yeah yeah it is
against the night King one of the
leaders so this could be indeed the
decisive game of the tournament for the
first place I want this Bravo probably
not allowed to use the internet after 10
p.m.
yeah I kind of don't think that's true
worse feed oh no it's not feed oh it's
made of feed oh yeah the people call
them feed oh I don't know perhaps have
you ever been to Denmark an you don't
know but actually I'm planning to go
next spring to Denmark to Copenhagen
yeah just to see what's what what do
they have to offer what to do they have
well they have some history of Vikings
which could be interesting okay so and
as I've heard they're aware it's a very
expensive country you could be the the
hiking Viking that could be the Viking
wagon yes oh the game is finished
okay what it's at least one point what's
a draw in the middle of the game I know
they just figured that it's better to
draw then to drag the game on you know
you lose less points no I think it's
like like a Chesbrough code in a bullet
tournament like you you just draw
quickly and then you beat other lower
radius players oh okay okay
oh there is a
still having a very close to 3,100 let's
see someone someone said if you type I
got matters log into Google that it it
says meadow that would be really cool we
should try that out after the turn yeah
definitely
okay what everyone's taking everything
more oddly still here oddly 2003 that's
obviously a you know Europe birth so
very like two young players yeah and
there it's up like like 30 yesterday 35
million rating very nice makes you think
huh yeah are we going to scream the
titled arena also well we're definitely
gonna check out the title the arena
black for sure
yeah we're also gonna be accepting some
challenges yeah we're just gonna show so
maybe how chess is play yeah actually
after this you know this is too much for
anyone to handle yeah they say you are
much that I'm much louder but but that's
like your general thing yeah always loud
maybe you could maybe we could like do
this so maybe this will now improve your
loudness okay she just started yelling
yeah and you're just further away from
from the they're just how it is
after all I'm just the tournament
director yeah silently okay eight
minutes to go Rebecca Harris still in
first a hundred and twenty five but
night King very close so it's basically
a Rebecca Harrison night who will be you
know finding it for the win I think
there's also who can read it the fifth
place okay penguin just one so I just
see his game fart the guy from North
arctica yeah I don't know it's like
penguin was the okay since this is a two
minute this is not you know penguins
happy hunting ground he he he prefers
hyper bullet but still
I'm very very impressive yeah for sure
I mean being top 5 with such range of
great layers oh this is so nice when the
night is coming to a 4 yeah good luck he
immediately know it's happening yeah oh
you know yonder the middle in Portuguese
means fear no I don't know if it's true
but did you check that no I didn't check
it what's a lot of people say it so I
didn't believe them in Portuguese means
fear okay
are you afraid when you walk in but
other people might read yeah yeah no
you're not
sometimes there are some people that are
weird
they're like Louie see like you're gonna
you know I don't bite me how would I
know
yeah like so so far he hasn't done
anything like that but you know asking
such a yes is a great dog yeah
can't imagine that happening honestly
okay this is a pretty equal game
I mean why can break through and be on
the beach yeah I thought they actually
they would they would just call it a
draw and you know but okay no other
games I mean listen so the situation is
oh okay
now anything could happen
no it's interesting okay there's an
penguin 19 seconds yeah that's that's a
problem yeah maybe for some people yeah
but not for him
we'll see and how is he gonna break this
how oh he's gonna infiltrate with the
king nice King before
to where what whoa what primo King c7
now that is a prized pre-move Andrew be
a little yeah no not now night Jim's
playing on time he sees that penguin is
too fast he's gonna try and try and flag
him
now you captured a six okay yeah capture
the pawn trade everything in yeah true
the porno or visual aid six what yeah
like should win whoa well he has to
guard me Hayden
yeah Wow he still has eight seconds he
played like this okay all of one's on
dark squares that's and now he just he
no play we will try to flag it the night
king do you think yes like I don't know
okay okay okay he could have kept and
okay no for the job but it's useless
so okay no okay now just remove the King
and dark squares and that's it
no he took the longer route okay look
he's losing no time that's actually one
of the things I enjoy only chess i think
i'm unsure calm if you pre move you lose
one tenth of a second yeah and I don't
know about other web sites but here you
can just pre move like to eternity that
was unreal
yeah the primo is real could never play
that fast okay Rebecca Harris still in
first three minutes and okay can anyone
take Rebecca Harris pledges at this
point I would keep watching the top
players play okay okay I mean we should
watch of one of the players who could
overtake him yeah there is a lost two of
his last games tall versus Koblenz or
Tolliver's between ik games six
yes both both incredible games but
gergan it's a versus now that is a game
that's it
okay draw okay
Angela either either okay Rebecca here
is still in first drew another game I
think all eraser says such a stupid site
I was leading by five points and they
banned a dude yeah as I was leading and
they neither banned the cheater like I
mentioned it 100 points yeah yeah
and I said he won't against the cheater
yeah so he did he didn't beat beat a
cheater yeah like I wouldn't take points
from him you know if he won against the
person who cheated yeah okay yeah
because here it's the point is to win as
many points as